my next guest is a social scientist who
has been studying the impact of
Technology and particularly that of
social networking and he's arrived to
some very different conclusions pleased
to be joined in the hood right here by
professor of communications
Keith Hampton of Rutgers University
thanks for being here appreciate this
this will be fun all right so you're
gonna be giving a keynote address
tomorrow but we're delighted to get a
chance to talk with you right now
help put research in focus don't forget
by the way to our online audience you
can join this conversation if you're
inspired something you've been wondering
about in this realm you can send your
questions in to me to Keith I'll relay
them here just use that tool right there
in the viewer there okay so Keith unlike
most speakers and attendees here at the
Microsoft faculty summit you're a
sociologist not a computer scientist but
that's not as anomalous as it might
first seem since first everyone on
Facebook knows computer technologies an
enormous impact on our social behaviors
that everywhere we look around
somebody's on their phone they're doing
it right so you're looking into just how
social media affects us both as
individuals as a society and before we
even get into your current research
about that I think our viewers would
probably like to know a bit more about
your background exactly how you got
interested in this line of research sure
I mean I got into this in the late 1990s
with a study of Wired suburbs actually
built north of Toronto and it was a
similar kind of moral panic of the day
about how broadband technology would
affect relation rights there was a lot
of concern that if you variety people
with a computer in their house and
everybody had one and he gave them
always-on internet access that they
would choose to abandon their neighbors
and other close relationships so I spent
two years moving into one such community
living in the neighborhood and studying
how those technologies were affecting
local relationships in those settings
Wow okay so it perhaps is just viewing
the past the rose-colored glasses but I
think most people believe that social
media has sort of been detrimental since
it replaced you know what a lot of
people think is Oh nobody talks anymore
nobody does face-to-face
person-to-person interactions it's all
kind of self-absorbed and tweets look
what I'm eating look what I'm doing look
where I'm vacationing
but that's of course just opinion how do
you actually study how technology in
particular social media has impacted our
social behaviors right so I mean I think
rose-colored glasses exactly the way to
frame it my talk tomorrow is about
whether the grass is in fact any greener
than it was in the past and I think that
every technological change is
accompanied by a concern about whether
those technologies are going to destroy
society destroy relationships make us
more alienated and this is really just
the latest one you know the ideal way to
study these is to be able to study them
over time in terms of some sort of
historical comparative way of measuring
change and lately we had one opportunity
to do that in studying how new mobile
phones technologies might be affecting
people in public spaces for example so
we got our hands on a series of super 8
films a really big archive people just
walking around in public spaces that was
taken about 30 years ago and those were
films that were taken to New York City
and Philadelphia and in Boston and we
were able to go back to the exact same
settings that those films were taken 30
years ago and take pictures today video
yeah and then we were able to compare
the content to the film 30 years ago to
the content of the film today see people
were more likely to be walking alone
see if there was a role for mobile
phones in these spaces to see if there
was any kind of change in the
composition of people's interactions in
those spaces mm-hmm and we observed
about a hundred and fifty thousand
people and our coding we did by hand I'm
not a computer scientist and what we
found was that over 30 years people are
in fact less likely to be walking alone
in public spaces but on people more
likely to spend time in groups those
groups tend to be more diverse people
for the most part weren't using their
mobile phones with public spaces they
belong to 10% in our most extreme cases
and in places where there were more
groups that's where people were less
likely to be using their mobile phones
it was really an activity that people
were doing when they would otherwise be
isolated in a public space okay so let's
talk about what about private as opposed
to the public spaces you know has social
media usage had a negative impact on our
closest relationships with friends
family at home right well again we had
an opportunity to do a bit of a
historical comparative study in this
in the 1980s and again in 2004 the
United States General Social Survey did
a series of questions to focus on
people's closest relationships and they
were able to model whether or not people
had fewer close ties today than they did
say 20 years ago the big and kind of
surprising finding of that was that they
found that the number of close ties that
people had had declined over time and
the diversity of those relationships had
declined as well the time period again
kind of matched to the rise of the
Internet the rise of home computing but
they didn't really have very good data
on whether or not individual uses of
those technology and how people were
using the technology were responsible
for any of that increase in our sort
decrease in the size of people's close
ties so I partnered with the Pew
Research Center's Internet and American
Life Project in 2009 and 2011 we did two
really big large national random surveys
of Americans right our we asked them
that same question that they asked in
the general social survey and what we
found was that in fact the number of
close ties people have doesn't seem to
be negatively affected by the use of
technologies in fact we've got no
negative relationships between people's
use of mobile phones social networking
sites internet use at all and having a
smaller core network on average Wow well
we did find is that people who use
social media in particular but also just
the Internet overall tend have more
close relationships and those
relationships tend to mean more diverse
they have more friends aren't just
family mm-hm
absolutely yeah I mean these networks
we've all created yes some people see it
as an obligation some people as you say
kind of create these networks of people
that they maybe don't see face-to-face
but that's not necessarily a bad thing
right well that's true although we do
find amongst our closest ties that new
technologies such as Facebook and other
kind of social networking term
technologies aren't really substituting
for face-to-face interaction if anything
they're adding on to it and we're
finding that the more people interact
with different types of digital
technologies the more they tend to see
each other in person as well and that's
especially true of our closest
relationships okay so what if we turn
our attention away from from just
individuals and now talk about society
more broadly let's talk about the impact
of social media on us as citizens voters
for instance out of social media of
affect our awareness of different points
of views obviously anyone who uses
Twitter he knows that it's kind of
become an information and a new source
in addition to just a way to have some
fun and share fun stuff yeah well again
through studies with Pew Internet and
early life we were able to find that the
average person who uses these new
technologies just internet use in
general and then the more they use
social media the more diverse their
networks tend to be so they do tend to
know people have a greater number of
different perspectives the people of
different social classes and kind of
span the whole social hierarchy yeah
yeah well and I think that's what at
least I would assume that that a lot of
folks are gonna go kind of hide in their
their pockets of social media in the
internet that they feel comfortable in
does this make us more aware of outside
perspectives does it silo us in those
little chat rooms where we converse with
only the people that are like-minded
well you know that's a more complicated
picture so we know from you know other
studies before the internet came along
that there's something called the spiral
of silence and that the more aware you
are of different points of view it
actually tends to reduce your ability to
have a democratic deliberation to some
sense so if you're aware that there's a
lot of disagreement and a social setting
that you're in just because of that
heightened awareness you may actually
feel less willing to speak out about
some probably yeah less likely to voice
opinions on political issues for example
right so I mean it's actually a nod a
little bit of a paradox you know we are
much more aware of that diversity around
us but that wariness of diversity may
also have this kind of negative effect
on us and that it makes us slightly less
willing to speak out when there's that
kind of uncertainty Wow okay well then
let's talk about the trickle down there
at the effect of social media on our
democracy is is affecting things like
voter participation involvement and
campaigning and so on I mean does it get
that far it's a great question you know
and there's a lot of difference between
you know democratic deliberation which
is what we're talking about in terms of
people's willingness to speak out and
Democratic participation and in fact
they may be very different things than
it there's some evidence to suggest that
you can't necessarily have a lot of
boast that places where there's a lot of
deliberation you start to appreciate the
other side more it actually may reduce
participation the son level but what
we're finding is again internet users in
general and particularly you
social media from another study we did
with the Pew Research Center we found
that they are in fact more likely to
attend political meetings they're more
likely to try and persuade other people
to vote and they're more likely to say
that they're going to vote themselves
right okay
well so let's take it down now to the
local level I understand you've also
investigated the impact of social
networks on neighborhoods what have you
learned about its effect on community
involvement in the neighborhoods in
specific right so after the net bill
study which is this project where I
spent two years doing this ethnography
I've done a series of other studies
where we observed how neighborhoods
change over time as a result of digital
technologies and one of the things we
found is that you know the simple
introduction of something like a
neighborhood discussion forum at the
local level has a lot of impact on local
relationships in fact we found that the
average person who uses such a
neighborhood discussion forum makes
about three new neighborhood social ties
in a year as a result which is fairly
significant over time that adds up to a
lot of relationships and of course you
know you don't have to be best friends
with your neighbors by any means it's
just really about awareness and that
awareness of people who are living in
your local community turns out to be the
most important thing when it comes to
things like organizing for collective
action dealing with local problems
whether it's crime or problems with a
meal carrier or something small and even
being able to help a neighbor who say
having some sort of local kind of
problem with health or something that
you can intervene with sure I can see
that okay well let's talk about your
your work more specifically your work is
actually indicating that social media
usages increases stress levels which I
guess isn't that surprising but but I
guess the question is - why is that
people are so aggravated trying to keep
up with the technology the obligation to
tweet right so this will be one of the
things I'm talking about tomorrow though
I'm making forward - and it's really
interesting it's really not the
technology that's raising people's
stress so what we found was that the
technology used itself how frequently
people are using something like social
media or their mobile phone or email
doesn't in itself tend to predict higher
stress in fact amongst women in
particular we found that the use of many
of these technologies was slower stated
with a slightly lower level of
psychological stress but what we did
find is that when we measure social
stress which is the stress that you get
from being aware of kind of the problems
and tribulations and other people in
your lives so when someone close to you
if they know someone who dies or they
know someone who's experiencing bad
health or has lost their job awareness
of those kinds of problems creates a
social stress that seems to be related
to social media use so those little bits
of information that we kind of wonder
how valuable they are as they come
through those different feeds they
really do add up to this kind of big
Gulf right yeah you know just one little
bit of information transits be really
significant if it's about a negative
thing that's happening in other people's
lives so it turns out that women in
particular but it's also true for men
but especially for women they are much
more aware of these kind of negative
life events that are happening around
them as a result of the exposure to
these little bits of information through
social media wow that's fascinating all
right you've inspired some of our online
audience as well right questions coming
in this one for you for Keith please
impart me in that I can relate to this
one right out of the gates please in
part one or two pearls of wisdom for a
parent with kids active on social media
especially with regards to safety being
able to know what might potentially hurt
others or even themselves we all worry
about you know kids when can sight
should I let them on the computer when
should I give them a phone that has
access to that social media has created
a whole other world I have a seven year
old and a four year old girl at home who
knows what things will be like by the
time they're on the phone on the
internet on social media what do you say
because I'm sure people find out what
you do they go oh so it should should I
let my kid on Facebook should I add them
on Twitter and again we all know someone
who is either lost a job or not gotten a
job because maybe something silly they
posted on social media you know it's an
incredibly difficult question to answer
I mean there are no really perfect
answers for this you know it's it's not
really a prescriptive thing I mean the
best thing that you can do I have a
seven-year-old a 10 year old myself
they're certainly not on most social
media but they're starting to text their
friends and things like that now and I
think that you know just having that
sense of trust with your kids early on
is really the most important thing when
it comes to using social media later
surveillance doesn't seem to work
cutting them off I don't think is
necessarily a good idea because these
technologies are really an important
part of use culture today and they
provide you know these kids with new
ways of interacting with very diverse
peers and gain the social support of
their peers
that may not have been available to us
say in the past so I don't think that
you know full-on surveillance is the
answer I don't think that cutting them
off is the answer but I do think you
know monitoring their use measuring
their use is important and assuring that
you know it doesn't you know crop up at
inappropriate times and helping them
learn the norms of acceptable use you
know so my house there are no devices
allowed at the kitchen table when we're
hatching dinner and things along those
lines and we know we measure how much
screens they have in general and I think
that that's an appropriate thing that we
would do when we're not just talking
about social media but about all media's
it's fascinating stuff we could talk all
evening I guess we'll just have to take
it to Twitter I think that I can fourth
question well thank you so much for your
time really my pleasure